fukima cétait le 11 mars il y a donc 3
mois cette semaine où en est-on là-bas
nos envoyés spéciaux al Chalvron syvain
Gillaume sont retournés à la limite de
la zone de sécurité à 20 km de la
centrale dévastée voici leur reportage
elle est bucolique la campagne autour de
Fukushima alternance de risier de forêt
nous sommes à 40 km de la centrale le
compteur GG marque 031 micro verte rien
d'inquiétant pourtant les villages
traversés sont morts pas de commerce pas
de
restaurant et ce vieux paysan a beau
dire que tout va bien il para bien
seul 30 km de la centrale le compteur g
monte un peu mais reste raisonnable
bizar alors que ce pmètre estcep d' évac
à tout moment une petite épicerie est
ouverteans que ce soit vraiment la
Jo on est de plus en plus
stressé toutes les familles sont
séparées dans des directions différentes
le pire c'est pour les enfants avant les
écoles étaient les meilleures de la
région mais aujourd'hui elles sont
fermées et les enfants sont
dispersés quelques kilomètres encore et
nous arrivons devant un barrage c'est la
zone d'exclusion on est à 20 km des
réacteurs endommagés personne ne passe
sauf autorisation spéciale et on ne
rigole pas je peux passer vous n'avez
pas d'autorisation monoc
mais c'est pas possible je suis désolé
vous devez faire demi-tour nous essayons
unereout de des
plusol
àéire général de la maous pouramou la
marchauss ici c'est la interdite qui
commence mais le barage est un peu plus
loin rien n'y fera pas d'exception
surtout pas pour les médias les règles
sont si strictes que le village est
coupé en
deux on ne peut rien
faire c'est le gouvernement qui a décidé
cette limite de 20 km qui coupe Kawi en
deux il faut l'accepter ils ont sûrement
de bonnes
raisons devenu post frontière en quelque
sorte kawaci a une nouvelle vocation
c'est le point de départ et de retour
des réfugiés du nucléaire autorisé à
aller pendant 2 heur dans leurs maisons
abandonnées aujourd'hui ils sont 212
originair de tomyoka à 6 km seulement de
la centrale à leur arrivé des équipes
spécialisées les oscult au compteur GG
ainsi que les affaires qu'ils ont
rapporté de leur maison un petit sac pas
plus j'ai pris des affaires d'été et
quelque chose de très précieux une photo
de mon père sur l de
Mor 2h c'est beaucoup trop
court au bout d'un he et de on commen
déjà à nous
stresser alors je n'ai pris que des
sous-vêtements lorsque du nucléaire qu
Kaw pour retrouver le de réfug une
douaine d'employés de leur font une
profonde
courbette c'est bien le
MO